ihre grüne Familienministerin gegen den
Liberalen Finanzminister
sagte fassungslos hat er hier auch noch
mal wiederholt ja ich weiß das habe ich
auch gelesen das finde ich natürlich so
ein bisschen bizarr nämlich er ist
immerhin der Parteivorsitzende der
Kanzlerpartei und in meinen Augen nimmt
es überhaupt nichts weg von der
Verantwortung von den Grünen von der
Verantwortung von der FDP aber in meiner
Analyse und die sage ich schon seit
vielen Monaten ist das Hauptproblem im
Kanzleramt und du kannst das selber
nämlich her ist der Regierungschef und
da geht's nicht darum dass er als
Regierungschef mit eigene Meinungen
vertreten darf nicht in seinem Streit in
Auseinandersetzung auch ganz hart für
seine eigene Position kämpfen muss aber
wenn man sich mal geeinigt hat und das
ist in meinen Augen das Problem dieser
Regierung dass diese Einigung wenn sie
stattgefunden hat dann nicht zählt
sondern man einigt sich
zum Teil noch wie lange hat Stars 36
Stunden oder sowas ja gut der eine
Koalitionsausschuss dann kommt ihre
Familienministerin und zerlegt das Ding
wieder Herr Habeck hatte dem doch
zugestimmt der Einigung über die
kriminierung ist das geht jetzt seit
vielen Monaten
unterschiedlichen Punkten und wenn sie
sozusagen so ein Zustand haben und als
jeweils jeder einzelne Ministerin und
Minister sehen dass der Regierungschef
dann nicht eingreift dann haben sie
sozusagen
die Zusage mit der Kindergrundsicherung
aber ich komme mich nicht drauf
verlassen
hat man den Effekt dass die Leute dann
jeweils einzeln gegeneinander gehen wir
gleich vier Leute die wirklich fragen
haben ich halte mich zurück also
sozusagen
und dann zieht Frau Pause zurück und
dann macht sie eine kündigt sie in der
Presse ruft sie die Presse zusammen alle
laufen dahin und dann macht sie wie bei
einem chinesischen Industrieminister
gibt es den Statement ab und lässt keine
Fragen zu das ist doch ein Problem der
Grünen und nicht das Kanzler das ist vor
allen Dingen die Führungsfläche von
deiner Arbeit das musst du doch ganz
klar sagen die Unterhändler verhandeln
im Vorfeld ja und wenn Frau Heiduk in
diesen Gesprächen Zusagen macht für
einen Kompromiss dann muss die
Führungskraft unter den Grünen in der
Lage sein das zusammenzubringen es kann
doch nicht sein dass sie das jetzt wie
beim Ukraine Krieg auf das Kanzleramt
projizieren das kann man es ist nicht
die Richtlinienkompetenz ist kannst
der Punkt ist dass jeder einzelne
Ministerin und Minister in dieser
Koalition erlebt hat ich habe eine
Zusage
aber ich brauche Druckmittel
um diese Zusage am Ende zu realisieren
das heißt es gibt einfach einen Mangel
von Vertrauen in dieser Koalition in dem
Kabinett das wenn ich meinen Druckmittel
zu früh aus der Hand gebe das dann die
Zusagen nicht eingehalten werden
Druckmittel ist ein schöneres Wort für
Erpressung
es ist in der Politik nicht unüblich
dass man sozusagen Dinge gegeneinander
verhandelt und dafür ist das schöne
Formulierung für Erpressung nein das ist
nicht Erpressung sondern nein es gibt
gegenseitige Kompromisse und wenn du ein
Zeitablauf hast das sozusagen der das
was dem einen zugestanden wird
heute beschlossen wird und das was man
dafür bekommen hat morgen beschlossen
wird würde ich aber nicht darauf
verlassen kannst wenn du heute ja sagst
dass morgen dein Partner auch ja sagt
Quatsch nein das ist handeln doch ihre
Leute mit die sitzen doch dann haben sie
einfach sozusagen ein Problem
Leute schlecht ist dass das Thema dann
haben sie einfach schließen sie haben
einfach einen Mangel anvertrauen
sozusagen ihre eigene Leute dann
schlecht was hast denn die eigenen Leute
hat Robert habe dann schlecht verhandelt
Robert habe hat sozusagen gesagt aus
seiner Sicht
passt der Kompromiss und wenn der
Kompromiss so kommen würde würde ja auch
passen es hat ja niemand was dagegen
dass Herr Lindner dieses Gesetz kriegt
die Kinder kann Punkt die
Kindergrundsicherung kommt dieses Gesetz
der Punkt ist nur offensichtlich ist das
Vertrauen und damit sind wir beim
Kanzleramt nicht groß genug noch mal
nicht groß genug dass am Ende das was
ausgehandelt worden ist wenn es dann
zeitliches Delta gibt dass das dann am
Ende und wie kann das denn sein das habe
ich ihr Chef also das entschuldigung ich
bin Parlament ich bin nicht klar
in Deutschland dass man immer so tut als
wenn es Parlament in die Kabinett ist
diszipliniert
und so weiter also persönlich mal ganz
kurz das hier ein insgesamt also ganz
ernsthaften selbstbewussteres Parlament
bräuchten das ein Parlament ist nicht
nur dazu da regierungs-
und so weiter und damit sind wir auch
schnell wieder bei der Ukraine wir haben
ganz viele cdu-kollegen gesagt sie
hätten sich gewünscht dass sie sich
getraut hätten als es damals um Nord
Stream 2 ging als es damals um Gasproben
ging dass sie damals der Regierung
widersprochen hätten also das sollte man
das schon unterschreiben
also die drei verhandeln das Lindner
Habeck und der Kanzler verhandeln lassen
die Stimmen zu mit anderen Worten habe
kann das Vertrauen dass das läuft
und dann kommt die Familienministerin
und Misstrauen nicht nur dem Kanzler
ganz offensichtlich wie Sie es
beschreiben sondern ja auch dem eigenen
Vizekanzler ich kann das sein sie
vertraut misstrau dir nicht dem
Vizekanzler weil sie das Ergebnis falsch
fand mit dem Gesetz dass ich das
Finanzministerium wünschte sondern sie
will das hat ihr eigener Mann verhandelt
mit dem Kanzler
besiegelt aber sie hatte auch gar nichts
gegen den Deal sie will ja nur nee nein
nein Sicherheit dass die Kinder kommen
kommt und ich meine Frage auch Christian
Lindner 2
sozusagen damit hatte war das sofort
Herr dürr immerhin Fraktionsvorsitzender
der FDP erklärt nee die Kinder
Grundsicherung das war alles so nicht
gemeint und ich glaube davon wissen sie
sich wieder raus
okay wenn die Regierung so wenig
Vertrauen untereinander hat
dann agieren aus nachvollziehbaren
Gründen Ministerinnen und Minister so
wenn ich mein Projekt durchkriegen will
brauche ich sozusagen
Erpressungspotenzial rauche ich ein
Druckmittel damit es am Ende auch
wirklich kommt und man hat es ja in der
Vergangenheit häufig sehen also was beim
Gebäude Energiegesetz passiert ist das
haben wir hier auch ausführlich
besprochen das war auch ein paar Minuten
war alles okay dann provozieren sie
jetzt die Nachfrage ist das eine Kutsche
dann dafür nein es ist nicht das Rache
wie du mir so ich dir nein nicht wie du
mir so ich dir sondern das Vertrauen ist
weg dass das gehaltene Worten ohne
Druckmittel eingehalten wird und damit
sind wir wie gesagt eins zu eins wieder
nein
sie will einfach schlichtweg dass die
hintergrundsicherung kommt und wenn Sie
jedes Druckmittel aus der Hand gibt dann
hat sie erlebt
das ganze Jahr davor das ist dann unter
Umständen nicht kommt und wenn du jetzt
vor der alternative stehst okay ich will
mein Projekt und
ich habe einen Druckmittel
und dann
wenn ich sozusagen das Druckmittel aus
der Hand gibt kommt mein Projekt
vielleicht nicht mehr
dann ist es erstmals
sie stellen auch gerade quasi mehrfach
fest dass diese Regierung von der
Atmosphäre von dem gestaltungswellen her
am Ende ist weil man sich so blockiert
dass man sich gegenseitig nur noch mit
Erpressung auf dem Weg bringen kann aber
auch inhaltlich
können wir ja noch mal darüber reden
natürlich hat die FDP die Kinder
Grundsicherung gewollt sie will die
Leistung zusammenlegen was total richtig
ist aber wo gehen Christian Lindner sich
wert und wie ich finde völlig zu Recht
dass man viel mehr Geld in einen
kaputtes System kippt und wo nicht weiß
ob das den Kindern wirklich nutzt mal
abgesehen davon dass nicht um nicht klar
ist vorher da die Summen kommen um das
zu bezahlen da hat dieser Pause einen
draufgelegt und darüber sollte man
ernsthaft reden in der Tat ist Kindern
mehr damit geholfen wenn die
Infrastruktur Schule und Bildung bezahlt
wird als wenn man den Eltern einfach
mehr Geld überweisen also erstens
wissenschaftlich
wenn sie sich die wissenschaftlichen
empirischen Daten anschauen was sie
gerade geäußert haben sondern damit es
funktioniert damit es auch mit der
Bildungsinfrastruktur klappt müssen die
Eltern aus dem Stress sozusagen dass sie
in so großen finanziellen
Schwierigkeiten kommen raus das sagt
nicht ich das sagen die ganzen
wissenschaftlichen Untersuchungen
wissenschaftlichen Untersuchung sagen
das ist wichtig ist die Eltern zu
ertüchtigen zu arbeiten
sie brauchen ausreichend Geld und sie
brauchen die Infrastruktur für die
Infrastruktur sind überwiegend die
Länder zuständig fürs ausreichende Geld
ist der Bund zuständig und dass das
System nicht funktioniert das ist ja
Konsens deswegen geht es ja darum die
Kindergrundsicherung einzuführen und das
bürokratische Chaos das bis dahin gab zu
beenden er fällt ja also noch mal zum
Verhandlungsprozess der Referenten
Entwurf ist am Ende der letzten Woche
vor der Sommerpause in die
Öffentlichkeit und ab Umgang in dieser
Phase werden alle möglichen Kritikpunkte
geäußert das heißt Frau Paus hat die
Gelegenheit zu sagen innerhalb ihrer
Gruppe also zuhören Habeck mach keine
Zugeständnisse weil ich will mein Pfand
nicht verlieren nicht aus der Hand geben
wenn er trotzdem die Zugeständnisse
macht muss ich eigentlich in der
Regierung davon ausgehen können dass
diese Frage geklärt ist ich meine wenn
das nicht der Fall ist ein letzter
Minute sozusagen das die Reißleine
gezogen wird dann ist das die
Führungsschwäche auf Seiten der Grünen
Parteien und sonst noch mal einen drauf
zu setzen Christian Lindner hat doch
schon zu Pressekonferenz geladen um das
Wachstum schussengesetz vorzustellen
also maximale typierung alle alle
Korrekturen die sowohl von grüner als
auch von SPD SPD-Seite gekommen waren
ausverhandelt und Frau Paus hat ohne
Abstimmung mit den eigenen Leuten dieses
Gesetz gestoppt genau das ist im Grunde
genommen nicht mit Robert habe nicht mit
der Parteiführung
von diesem Putschversuch also das ist ja
kein spekulativ ich glaube Herr Feld war
nicht dabei der sitzt nicht sozusagen im
Ohr von kostenlos
oder von Herrn Habig nein natürlich
nicht ich bin Parlament
ja noch ja ich nehme mal an dass sie das
einfach schlichtig im Kabinett
entsprechend beschlossen und besprochen
haben und wie gesagt sie hat's in der
Kabinetts Abstimmung dafür gibt's die
Kabinett Abstimmung sagt nein sie ist
damit in der Form nicht einverstanden
nämlich
also ich nehme an dass die das Kabinett
schon besprochen haben aber das ist wie
gesagt
zum Beispiel sie wussten nicht ja
natürlich weiß ich sowas nicht ich meine
es ist ja bizarre sozusagen
das Parlament sozusagen Details der
Kabinetts Abstimmung wissen sollte also
wenn man das einführen würden dann sind
wir überhaupt nicht mehr in der Lage
irgendwas umzusetzen also würde ich mich
auch ehrlich
das stimmt also das stimmt überhaupt
alles gut
wirklich
sie haben Recht diese Regierung macht
der auf jeden Fall dann eine ganze Menge
ja aber was in der öffentlichen Debatte
immer hängen bleibt sind genau diese
kommunikativen Katastrophen nein es sind
nicht kommunikative Katastrophen sondern
es sind Streitereien und
Interessenskonflikt sind und damit bin
ich wieder beim Kanzler nämlich eine
Regierung die so aktuell sozusagen dem
sie eine nicht kommunikative nördigkeit
attestiert haben ja ich meine der taucht
kommunikative nördigkeit ja der Tausch
was heißt das autistisch oder oder der
taucht einfach immer wieder über Wochen
weg und man kriegt nicht mit weil in der
Öffentlichkeit welche Position der hat
und das in so einer schwierigen Lage und
Freitag beim Thema industriestrompreis
auch ja so ein Lieblingsthema der
Kanzler sich ja zum Beispiel sehr klar
positioniert dagegen
guten Gründen den fordern ja die Grünen
den fordern ja auch die
Wirtschaftsverbände und das andere Leute
auch zum Beispiel Lars klingelt
gestern war
glaube ich ist
spd-parteivorsitzender der forderten
auch das macht das ja alles nicht
richtig da werden 2000
Industrieunternehmen gefördert mit
Milliarden die der Steuerzahler die
Kassiererin der Krankenpfleger bezahlt
und 38.000 andere Industrieunternehmen
müssen sehen wie sie klarkommen zum
Beispiel zu sagen wer hat Becker muss
auch sehen wie er seinen Ofen
klimaneutral hinkriegt und ThyssenKrupp
kriegt zwei Milliarden bezahlt für einen
Hochofen natürlich können Sie sozusagen
sagen dass diese Energiepreis Schock
unter dem unsere Wirtschaft leidet dass
das einfach pech für die Unternehmen ist
und die sollen jetzt einfach mal schön
pleite gehen und die ganzen
Arbeitsplätze gehen verloren sie
zerstören hat damit das Ökosystem der
deutschen Wirtschaft nämlich es ist nur
das Problem alleine klarkommen ist
das findet der handwerkspräsident sagt
bleibt mir weg mit dem
industriestrompreis wir Mittelständler
wir Handwerker müssen das Problem auch
selbst lösen und die Industrie wird da
gepampert ausgerechnet eine alte
Industrie die auch noch für viele
Emissionen zuständig ist also sie haben
glaube ich einfach nur total
theoretischen Vorstellung von Wirtschaft
Präsidenten rufen Sie an mit Wirtschaft
gut funktioniert brauchen Sie zum
Beispiel sowas wie eine Stahlindustrie
da brauchen sie sozusagen für ein
Industrieland also was wir eine
Chemieindustrie sie brauchen
letztendlich die gesamte Lieferkette sie
brauchen ein Ökosystem des entsprechend
in sich funktioniert sie können sich da
theoretische Modelle überlegen und das
ganz abstrakt machen aber so
funktioniert halt Wirtschaft nicht
deshalb empfiehlt sich da immer am
ersten mit dem Praktikern zu reden die
betroffen sind Handwerks Präsident
stellt keinen Stahl her der ist
sozusagen auch keine
Kunststoffindustrie sondern erster
Handwerks Präsident und das Modell des
industriestrompreises funktioniert so
dass
energieintensive Unternehmen die
aufgrund des externen Shops über den man
vorher gesprochen haben nämlich das
Russland sozusagen als billiger
Energielieferant von heute auf morgen
weggefallen ist wird diesen Industrie in
einer Übergangszeit geholfen bis der
Strompreis entsprechend wieder billig
ist nämlich wenn wir die erneuerbare
Energien zehn Jahre schnell ausbauen
dann wird es entsprechend
vorbei ist wir haben nicht genug
erneuerbare Energien ausgebaut wir
brauchen ganz viel Strom für
Elektromobilität und ihre geliebten
Wärmepumpen das wird den Strompreis so
stark über lange Sicht treiben dass wir
nicht sicher wissen dass in 10 Jahren
wieder abgeschafft worden außer der
eg-umlage sowas bleibt
in Richtung Position haben aber solo
jetzt bitte für sie würde es gerne
einmal verstehen weil hier ein topökonom
sitzt schon mehrfach erwähnt aber Sie
müssen jetzt auch sprechen bitte sie
sind komplett gegen diese Subvention sie
sagen das wir sollten wir so nicht
machen das ist nicht gut für uns
und natürlich fragt man sich warum ist
das nicht gut für uns weil wir natürlich
ein Land sind das von der industriellen
Wertschöpfung immer sehr gelebt hat und
die Gefahr natürlich da ist auch wenn
man die großen dann so hört Herrn
brudermüller von BASF und andere die
sagen ja also so können wir das hier
nicht weitermachen wir gehen entweder in
die USA oder wir gehen nach China auf
jeden Fall sind wir bald weg und sie
sagen trotzdem dann lass sie ziehen im
Zweifel oder was ist dann die Antwort
darauf Zweifel werden sie nicht ziehen
das ist entscheidende Punkt der
entscheidende Punkt ist der dass die
Drohungen die aufgebaut werden von der
energieintensiven Wirtschaft gegenwärtig
nur darauf abzielen die Subvention
abzukassieren und zwar möglichst
dauerhaft das hat er Bedi Präsident auch
sehr deutlich gesagt vor der Sommerpause
das ist kein brückenstrompreis ist die
Brücke gibt es nicht sondern es wird so
sein dass wir mit einer Dauer Subvention
zu rechnen haben wenn dieser Industrie
oder Jahrzehnte
wir brauchen eine Stahlindustrie das ist
ein Argument das haben wir in den 60er
70er 80er Jahren 90er Jahren andauernd
gehört mit großer Mühe sind wir aus der
subventionieren der Stahlindustrie
herausgekommen und haben dann Kohle
immer noch bis zuletzt zu pensioniert
immer mit diesen Argumenten nein wir
müssen nicht die wesentlichen Elemente
der Wertschöpfungskette in Deutschland
herstellen okay aber wir haben
internationalisierte werkstattungsketten
darauf kommt es an okay
ThyssenKrupp z.B da geht's um die Frage
Beispiel nehmen wir lieber ein Konzern
der 2019 besser da stand als zwischen
Gruppe nämlich
von Stahl
reden thyssenKrupp hat das Problem eben
schon auch gehabt dass sie aufgrund von
falschen Management Entscheidungen eine
ganze Reihe von wirtschaftlichen
Problemen hatten und deswegen war
überhaupt nicht klar und es ist im
Grunde auch heute nicht ähm wie wie
gesund da steht und inwiefern das was
wir an Subvention das heißt
speziell es geht darum müssen das
Umstellen Stahl sehr sehr
energieintensiv es geht um grünen
Wasserstoff nicht in blauer oder sonst
grüner Wasserstoff das heißt hergestellt
mit der regenerativer Energie das ist
sehr sehr teuer und sie sagen wenn die
das nicht selber können dann sind die
weg wir sind doch sowieso schon dabei im
Zuge von differenzverträgen der
energieintensiven Wirtschaft den er die
Umstellung des Kapitalstocks also der
Anlagen die Sie brauchen um mit hohen
Energiewerten ihre Produktion machen zu
können zu subventionieren das machen wir
mit hohen Beträgen ja und thyssenKrupp
hat ja bereits in diesem Zusammenhang
einen sattencheck gekriegt beim
industriestrompreis wird jetzt noch
zusätzlich eine Subventionierung der
Betriebskosten vorgenommen also das was
wir kontinuierlich variabel an weiteren
Kosten haben okay ja und die Vorstellung
dass wir innerhalb von fünf Jahren
beim Strompreis runterkommen werden ist
eine falsche wir werden dauerhaft höhere
Strompreise haben wir wollen doch mit
der co2-bepreisung die Energie verteuern
im Zeitablauf das ist dann die
Konsequenz der fällt wenn die gehen die
Pleite sind die weg passiert das was in
den USA passiert ist dass wir dann die
Stahlarbeiter die Stahlkocher nicht mehr
also in den USA gibt sie Stahlkocher ja
immer noch ja und wir haben ja selber
immer wieder Leute getroffen die genau
in Ohio und anderswo die genau das
erlebt haben dass diese Stahlindustrie
dann nach China nach Indien und sonst so
abgewandert ist und als man den dann
sagte etwas auf das können die Kinder
und die Chinesen jetzt besser und die
sagten die finden wir jetzt hoch dann
sagt man den auch noch ja als Rassisten
bei dir hat was gegen ihn und Chinesen
so geht's aber nicht daraus beißt sich
ein Teil der Wut die dann dazu geführt
hat dass Trump ins Weiße Haus gekommen
ist ja
die Situation der Grund warum tragen
vielfältig aber das ist einer der Gründe
ja es ist sicher einer der Gründe dass
die der chinesische Wettbewerb in
den USA andere Auswirkungen hatte für
Deutschland wir haben in Deutschland ja
dadurch auch eine entsprechende
Strukturwandel gehabt und sind mit dem
Strukturwandel relativ gut zurecht
gekommen insgesamt hat das was die
Hinzunahme von osteuropäischen Staaten
und China in die internationale
Arbeitsteilung gebracht hat zu
Arbeitsplatzverlust sind bestimmten
Regionen geführt dafür haben wir
Regionalpolitik gemacht um die Leute
besser zu tüchtigen nach woanders zu
arbeiten und per saldo ist die
Beschäftigung bei uns gestiegen und das
Bruttoinlandsprodukt bei uns gestiegen
in den USA gibt es eben auch diese
sozialen Absicherung nicht wir haben
keine soziale Absicherung in den USA
über eine Regionalpolitik die ähnlich
wäre und auch nicht über
sozialstaatliche Maßnahmen wie sie in
Deutschland existieren dann sind
natürlich die Enttäuschungen in den USA
größer ja wir haben in Deutschland eben
auch ein Netz das bei solchen
Strukturwandlungen auffängt aber den
Strukturwandel hemmen zu wollen
genauer Subventionen führt nicht zu dem
Zeitpunkt
nicht darum ein Strukturwandel mit
dauer-subventionen zähmen sondern wir
haben eine absolut einzigartige
Situation nämlich durch den Krieg den
Überfall Russlands auf die Ukraine haben
wir ca 50% unserer fossilen
Energieversorgung de facto über Nacht
verloren und für Unternehmen ist es
immer möglich sich einzustellen auf
langfristige sehr grundlegende
Veränderung aber wir haben eine massiven
Energiepreis Schock und es geht darum
für eine temporäre Zeit den Unternehmen
die Möglichkeit zu geben diesen
Industriepreis Schock
entsprechend zu verarbeiten sich
umzustellen sich weiter zu entwickeln
aber sie nicht sozusagen ins offene
Messer laufen zu lassen nee ich wenn man
solche externen Shops nicht abfedert
treibt man sozusagen die die
Industrialisierung des landesfrauen das
wollen wir nicht den Kopf mit Blick auf
BASF sagten sie vorhin größter
Chemiekonzern der Welt
Ammoniak Grundstoffe all diese Dinge
sehr energieintensiv so wird immer
weniger gemacht auch in Deutschland
kostet Arbeitsplätze die sagen ja wir
gehen jetzt nach China weil da kriegen
wir den grünen Strom den wir brauchen
und so weiter weniger regulatorik das
ganze Thema macht dir das keine Sorge
dass das die den Laden dann einfach zu
machen am Standort Deutschland da mehr
machen abwanderungs Tendenzen von
Unternehmen immer Sorgen es geht ja
dabei in diesem Standortwettbewerb darum
zu fragen wo finden diese
Erweiterungsinvestitionen statt nur die
Hoffnung über eine Subventionierung des
industriestroms die Energiekosten dieser
Unternehmen
nur eine kurze Zeit so niedrig zu halten
dass sie bleiben und dauerhaft hier
bleiben können ist verfehlt wir werden
die Preise auf Dauer haben in der
Abdeckung ist es dann besser wenn wir
diesen strukturwandeln wie es dann so
als vermisstisch heißt hinleben dann
gehen die halt nein dann müssen sie
fragen bei solchen Kosten Komponenten
können wir denn ansetzen um gewisse
Erleichterung dabei zu führen die
Entscheidung für die BASF nach China zu
gehen ist doch unabhängig gewesen von
dieser Energiefrage das stimmt ist schon
lange vorher getroffen worden es ging
vor allen Dingen darum den Markt zu
erschließen und die Zugeständnisse die
chinesische Führung an BASF gemacht hat
noch einmal besondere ja und ähnlich ist
es in Autoindustrie wenn man sich die
Subventionen für E-Mobilität in China
anschaut dann wird natürlich auch
versucht dort die Subventionen zu
realisieren aber das ist jetzt nicht für
sich genommen von dem energiepreisschock
abhängig den Herr Hofreiter beschreibt
aber in den 80er und 70er Jahren
Energiepreis gehabt haben genau die
gleiche Diskussion gehabt und deshalb
für die Industrie mit Erleichterung die
an anderer Stelle geschaffen worden sind
kein Problem bereitet diesen Wandel zu
bewältigen okay und umgekehrt immer wir
reden ja auch über Industrie des 19 und
20 Jahrhunderts wenn es um sozusagen das
geht was Zukunft ist also
elektroautomobilindustrie und so weiter
da sehen wir mittlerweile ziemlich
ziemlich alte aus wenn man sich auch
anschaut wie viele Autos aus China
mittlerweile hier ankommen in wenigen
Jahren wenn es 800.000 und mehr sein das
sind ja alles Thema über die reden
müssen gleichzeitig im Massenmarkt in
China verliert VW massiv maganteile das
heißt die haben dann echtes Problem und
deswegen brennt in Wolfsburg glaube ich
gerade ein bisschen der Baum
es ist dann richtig zu sagen okay dann
subventionieren wir das was wir für
Technologie der Zukunft halten Intel
TSMC zum Beispiel mit sehr sehr viel
Steuergeld bis zu 2,53 Millionen pro
Arbeitsplatz Magdeburg Dresden und so
weiter weil wir glauben das ist das was
in Zukunft uns voranbringt ist das dann
richtig ich bin bei diesen Subventionen
für bestimmte Endprodukte immer
skeptisch würden sie auch nicht machen
nein ich würde ich hätte hier SMC und
Intel nicht gefördert wir müssen uns mal
von den Rahmenbedingungen die wir haben
abzuschichten wir haben weil sich China
ansprechen ein Problem dass ich vor
allen Dingen durch die geostrategischen
Rivalitäten Ergebnisse das ist eine
Rivalität des Westens mit China und
anderen Staaten es ist nicht nur eine
Frage des Handelskonflikt USA
und der Grund der der oder das was ich
daraus ergibt für Deutschland heißt ist
natürlich dass wir in Zukunft ein
schlechteres Geschäft mit China machen
können das geht für alle ja das ist ein
zusätzliches Problem ein Schock den wir
eben schon angesprochen haben und
eigentlich eher im Hinblick auf das was
sie als Geschäftsmodell bezeichnet haben
im Ausblick eine größere Schwierigkeit
als dass wir jetzt bei der Energie
beschreiben können ja
wir müssen also erstens feststellen was
benötigen wir denn im Hinblick auf die
sicherheitspolitischen Fragestellungen
den wir uns zu stellen haben an
Produktion in Europa oder im Westen okay
kommt es darauf an dass die Koordination
im Westen funktioniert okay das unsere
Zusammenarbeit mit den USA entsprechend
ist es ist es wäre fatal wenn wir
einerseits in einem Subventionswettlauf
und andererseits in positionistische
Maßnahmen der USA gegen Europa und
Europas gegen die USA laufen wir müssen
in dieser sicherheitspolitischen
Konstellation zusammen das verstehe ich
und dann benötigen wir Handelsverträge
mit den USA mich vielleicht auf diesem
hohen Niveau das ttip haben solltest
sondern abgeschichtet auf kleineren
Handlungsfeldern und kommen auf die Art
und Weise voran aber es würden
abschließend gefragt sagen es läuft
leider ein bisschen die Zeit davon
Russland war vor ein großer Schwerpunkt
sie will abschließend sagen wir die
Amerikaner das machen massiv
subventionieren und fördern dann ist es
okay aber wenn wir das in Magdeburg
machen ist nicht gut das ist nicht das
was ich sage also im Grunde ist ja das
ist
doch eine Reaktion auf das was wir
Europäer schon lange machen es ist doch
nicht so dass wir im Bereich des
Klimaschutzes über die Jahre nicht
subventioniert hätten die eg-umlage ist
wenn ich über den Haushalt gelaufen und
das wird deswegen auch nicht rechtlich
als Subvention gerechnet aber sie ist
über die Stromrechnung gelaufen das war
eine Subvention faktisch wir machen mit
Next Generation weniger in Deutschland
aber im Rest Europas massive Förderung
für den Klimaschutz also das was die USA
jetzt im Volum en machen mag vielleicht
am Ende weil es eben ein Text credit ist
ein größeres Volumen erreichen aber es
wird doch nur nachvollzogen als
Subventionen was wir eben Europa die
ganze Zeit schon machen jetzt noch mal
eins draufzusetzen mit noch mehr
Subventionen beschleunigt diesen
Subventionswettlauf und ist zum Schaden
dieser beiden Seiten und schwächt uns
gegenüber dem sicherheits-